grab your tissues or maybe a barf bag
because Haley beaver just gushed over
her hubby Justin Bieber in a very epic
very public way it's a no-brainer these
two are head over heels and are no
strangers to declaring their love for
each other on social media on Wednesday
Haley was added again sharing this sweet
pic of her man alongside the caption my
love you are an incredible man you make
me a better human being you make me
happier than I've ever been insanely
proud of who you are and who you're
becoming I love you more every single
day he's really funny we have a good
time together he's just really sweet
he's a good kid
he's a good heart and what do you mean
Haley's heartfelt message comes less
than two weeks after Justin penned a
heartfelt poem for her that he shared on
Instagram yeah you heard that right the
Biebs is a poet and he doesn't care who
knows it
channeling his inner Shakespeare the pop
star wrote quote I fall more in love
with you every day you have walked hand
and hand with me as I continue to get my
emotions mind body and soul intact you
have given me so much strength support
encouragement and joy I just wanted to
publicly honor you and remind you that
the best is yet to come
okay so this is the sweetest but also I
do feel like I need to note the
excessive use of exclamation points like
is he yelling I fall more in love with
you every day exclamation point anyway
it's been nearly seven months since
these little lovebirds tied the knot in
a secret ceremony last September in New
York City and they've been couple goals
ever since
and while Haley has inspired Justin's
poetry she may just be inspiring some
new music to on Wednesday Justin dropped
a teaser for his upcoming collaboration
with comedian and rapper lil Dicky
titled earth
oh and no big deal but other artists
involved include
ariana grande Miley Cyrus Halsey Snoop
Dogg Rita Ora Katy Perry Zac Brown
Brendon Urie Wiz khlifa Shawn Mendes
Charlie puth Hailee Steinfeld Ed Sheeran
Adam Levine SIA John Legend Backstreet
Boys Kevin Hart Miguel lil yachty Meghan
Trainor bad bunny benny blanco leonardo
dicaprio wait Leonardo DiCaprio I've
missed you Justin bring that music we
are here for it and we'll be here to
keep you up-to-date on all the latest
Justin music so be sure to keep it
locked on ET until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]